a tubers is Charlie to this is gonna be
my got them episode eight video
Harvey Dent we get to me legalistic us
to as the illustrious
Harvey Dent accords he's gonna show up
again maybe not that many times this
season he said he didn't know how many
times he be back
I know everyone's wondering did not
gonna turn amended to face right away
even though there are some really
interesting cues they can line up with
his back strain the comic that I'll
explain
next week will be the midseason finale
but it's already been picked up for a
full season
I believe it's twenty episodes total but
although residents will happen in spring
so a lot of some Batman comic books that
the talk about but let's start with top
five moments care for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet
starting with number five black a
penitentiary so the funny thing about
Black Gate
is that it was featured in the Chris
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
if you ever as a result are the events
during Dark Knight they created the
Harvey Dent act
that took the worst inmates from Arkham
and put them in Black Gate
in this episode they were doing reverse
which is kinda funny so it was like
they're taking the worst inmates putting
them in Arkham
I don't know how they're going to
reconcile that cut newtie will just look
at this cop in TV shows being its own
separate thing for now
they're just a whole lotta things in
general but the Chris Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy that didn't necessarily line up
with the comic books in the cartoons and
stuff so
actually I think it's better to say the
Chris Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy can
take this by itself
TV shows in general especially right now
all that easy TV shows
are very loyal to the comics much more
so than the movies
speaking on my eyes number for meet
lovecraft
new big bad Declo craft as teas this
episode
is probably that evil person on the wane
board it behind the Benazir
as well as the way murders no he didn't
kill himself but I do think that he's
tied to the murders
it's a bit of a surprise because he's
presented is be just as powerful as
falcone Maroni
that makes him almost invincible which
takes into big bad status
like 12 the big onto the season about
the people you could think up
as the big don't this season if you like
he's the one the writers what you hate
the most
it's like the whole conflict with fish
moody falcone Maroni
makes you want to root for falcone
especially since the penguin really
seems like the protagonist
and he is the one with Falcon right now
there on the good team
if you gonna pick favorites amongst the
villains that brings up a really
important issue I feel like there are a
few the villains this season their
little
developed so I think it's going to take
the next ten episodes
before we really decide who the real
villain is for now though
lovecraft will do and I suspect that
he's named after HP lovecraft
lovecraft I'll talk about lovecraft a
little bit more when I talk about
Arkham Asylum just because there's so
much influence
bouncing back and forth between HP
Lovecraft's universe in the Batman
universe
number three batman & Catwoman by part
the most fun part of the episode
some other interactions ran a little
slow but I did like the playfulness
between them
catwoman is one of the few characters
taken get through his armor like get to
the real Bruce Wayne
that we see Selina Kyle calling bullshit
on most is that he does in this episode
she just
books so many holes in it I was in a
performance that you really good for a
couple backers their age
hopefully they'll get a chance to
develop their relationship whatever
that's going to look like
over the next two three four five
seasons we don't have gotten gonna get a
season two yet but it has been a ratings
hit for Fox so I think it has a strong
chance
depending on how some of those episodes
in the back after you number two
Arkham is reopened all the worst
prisoners are dumped in
I try to keep my eyes peeled for
prisoners walking up the bus to sleep
and even look familiar
aside from in hargrove the criminal from
this episode I didn't recognize any
specifically
ahead hope it's been a little bit more
time at our command first happened this
season
but it looks like that's what they did.
saving for the second half just explain
the Lovecraft aspect in Arkham Asylum
the actual building itself Arkham Asylum
when it was created in the comics
was named after the town Arkham in HP
Lovecraft's Cthulhu stories
that is why it looks so hot it in creepy
the writers meeting with the mayor
only did that only said all the
prisoners to our camp because they were
cordoned said
he might have the plan all along if you
don't member from the last couple
episodes he's pretty clearly in
collusion with the mob primarily falcone
lovecraft to lovecraft also has a
controlling interest
in Arkham City so it's like lovecraft
the mob
in anyone else that we haven't met yet
are potentially haven't met yet
have their hooks into the air and mares
trying to deal with all them
I know there's the temptation to think
up Richard kind the mayor
as an evil character but really he's the
bullock the politicians in the city
they take both for instance he's not a
dirty cop
but he is caught up with the mob
to push comes to shove there's a good
chance he'd roll over for falcone or
when the other big mobsters
the mayor is it a more powerful version
that character although there have been
a few theories
that he is the one that killed the
wayne's I kill them himself I don't know
that's true but I do like that idea
and whenever one moment meet Harvey Dent
played by Nicolas de costo
at looking at him he has some big shoes
to fill big coin to flip
if you never actually read the
inscription on this point it reads
ordered it done
but to an let them hate as long as they
fear explain the point during the Dark
Knight trilogy but
basically his father was really abusive
in with flip the coin to give them a
chance to avoid beatings
I know I've recommended the Gotham
central comics just because it centers
on the Garden City Police Department
just like the show garden does in that
continuity to face balls in love with my
Toyota
in that going sideways out there is a
lesbian the kids keep back into Arkham
for the midseason finale 30 things
intention with corn
but I don't think that they're going to
do any big to face stories outside at
this
I know everyone's wondering when is he
going to become to face just because
he's a little bit older
they could do that sooner right now he's
counselor dent
I don't think that he would become to
face italy became the district attorney
in only then after being district
attorney for a long time
got them is a prequel shoot so I don't
expect to see any poll on super Don't
Tell season to season 3
and did they can go that long without
showing someone in a costume
soon expect anyone to throw any acid on
anyone's bases anytime soon
the interesting thing is that they're
teasing his big mob trial like to try to
go after lovecraft
you that a mobster but in the comics it
was while they were trying to take down
a mobster the degas taciturn his face it
was inside the courtroom
there been a lot of different origin
stories for to face so the details about
that using a change is a little bit each
time
of course most fun part was when he
flipped out on lovecraft
the comics have explained his Harvey
Dent identity versace's to face identity
in slightly different ways
typically it's dissociated identity
disorder
it's not like bruce barren the whole
crew anything like that only one
identity can be present
in typically you don't see him spending
a lot of time when he's in one percent
thinking about the other persona like
when he's Harvey Dent you don't see him
thinking about to face very often
and when he's two faced you see him
thinking about Harvey Dent that often
I was a baller Batman don't that govern
could possibly do Harvey Dent
is one of the more interesting was just
because he's a tragic villain there's
even this run in the comics per to face
worked with Batman but usually at some
point he'll get restored to become party
den something terrible happen
to turn back in the two-phase so it's
like he keeps bouncing back and forth
like he gets redeemed
any falls down again then gets her team
falls down again
if you guys wanna read some really
awesome to face stories though one is I
the beholder
see six min long Halloween that's just
an awesome comic in general
have a life that XD card from Central
Park
happen evil thats Batman number 234
and then faces thats Batman legends The
Dark Knight
number 28 to 30 I think imagine most to
the Easter eggs are ready
I give the person to be but thats just
because I felt like the in hargrove
storyline like that concern line
just did not work for an episode that
supposed to tee up a finale I feel like
it just didn't quite live up to the
standard
nichols to got those Harvey Dent best
thing about the episode hands down
worst thing about the episode I would
say would be Barbara you get a good look
at them that
thumbs-down kind of thing thumbs down
for Barbara thumbs up for Harvey Dent
maybe I should flip a coin to be more
appropriate the only thing that I'm not
enjoying about the barber character
right now
is the fact that she is not a character
I understand the trying to create some
tension with the character did
has been featured in the comments a
whole lot but we don't see a lot of
Gordon's bike typically they're divorced
by the time you see in me because you
seem as Commissioner Gordon most the
interaction we've had with the rest of
his family in the comics is
group are brought to his daughter
Barbara the same thing to really happen
on a rope with the a in Laurel
the writer said that per season 1&2 they
were just the hardest people to write
for
in order for a character to be worthy
our admiration
they have to go through a crucible
cordons going through one right now
Bruce is going through one right now
penguin went through one already
just think about all the characters you
live on the show the probably the once
it had something really terrible happen
to them indeed trent over
even a model I love in this episode part
of the problem with that
is just the amount of time they had to
spend I characters I feel like barbara
will get her do eventually
yes cheating on board with my toy is
tantalizing but if you there are so many
other things they could do with her
character do would make her more
interesting
they did you get into her family life
she's from a very powerful family
what's her father been doing this whole
time in
all fairness I do think the back after
the season will deal with that
use largely absent from the episode
totally love the pain when though
for the time he was on screen he has the
best the music I got them
that you give you an idea about who the
writers want you to read for
penguin cordoned falcone KMA and Bruce
Wayne
Kalamazoo with or in their next week's
episode is called not crap be sure to
subscribe to maybe up opposite right up
to the episode airs
I will be doing bonus videos in the
offseason I'll be doing you know batman
more videos so just leave your request
in the comments if you have any specific
I me to start with
in just had that because YouTube has
changed a few things gimme some extra
features
the links that I put it in the videos
will change just a little bit
also have like my special links here but
if you're on mobile you can actually
click up here to get those links to now
as always everything's in description to
but right now click here
for last week's got them and click here
to get ready for the class this week
thank you so much for watching now talk
about I'll see you guys tomorrow